[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec vous
nommez garbade chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris bonsoir à vous sabrina délits
qu'on fondatrice du cercle des proches
aidants en ehpad bonsoir à vous aussi
merci d'être là enfin philippe
vayssettes président de la fédération
des syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être avec
nous alors d'à peine 10 % le variant
delta représente donc désormais 20% des
cas de komi diagnostiqués en france
selon le ministre de la santé
mais on peut tu y échapper même si c'est
une progression plutôt fulgurante
philippe vayssettes vous êtes inquiet
par ces chiffres ou vous partager le
diagnostic plutôt rassurant d'olivier
ferrand oui on le diagnostic de lévis
verrons il est fondé sur le lit dès que
tout le monde va finir par comprendre
qu'il faut se faire vacciner et donc
nous savons maintenant les doses enfin
nous avons les soignants suffisamment
insuffisante pour vacciner
nous avons donc eu toute la logistique
qui maintenant permet d'avoir sans
attente la possibilité de se faire
vacciner
donc il faut vraiment que tout le monde
vienne se faire vacciner est comme ça
nous serons enfin débarrassé de cette
problématique virale enfin c'est le
c'est du bon sens et oui je suis
d'accord avec le ministre à partir du
moment où on est vacciné contre lacko
vide et bien c'est nous aurons la
possibilité
j'espère d'avoir une quatrième vague qui
peut être arrivera mais ne fera pas de
dégâts et d'une embolie sera pas nos
hôpitaux etc et surtout surtout pour les
gens parce que tout le monde en connaît
maintenant dans ses proches qui sont qui
ont une accusation qui sont en
réanimation n'auront pas à vivre ce
calvaire brune ambrée herman vous vous
partagez ce diagnostic de philippe
besset
et d'olivier véran oui on peut encore y
échapper grâce à la vaccination et grâce
au traçage philippe a b c est plutôt
optimiste en disant les gens vont finir
par comprendre qu'il faut se vacciner
c'est votre avis aussi
alors si vous voulez le variant delta va
inéluctablement remplacer les autres
variantes donc d'ici la fin de l'été
la quasi-totalité des variantes qui vont
circuler sur le territoire seront liés à
ce variant delta c'est quelque chose qui
ne dépend pas de nous c'est lié à la
sélection des virus entre eux
maintenant effectivement comme ça a été
dit l'ensemble des vaccins dont nous
disposons sont parfaitement efficace
pour protéger contre les formes graves
et les formes mortelles de la commune 19
et compris celles liées à tous les
variants dont le variant delta il faut
donc évidemment se protéger à l'échelle
individuelle pour ne pas faire une forme
grave et mourir et par ailleurs il faut
vacciner le plus grand nombre pour
réduire la circulation du virus et
protéger les quelques personnes qui
n'auraient pas été vaccinés et donc
évidemment je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec eux ce qui a été dit ainsi que la
stratégie aujourd'hui pour permettre en
septembre d'éviter un rebond hospitalier
des infections liées à la coved 19 et
probablement en rapport avec le variant
delta il faut vacciner le maximum de
personnes
et bien si il faut surtout vacciner la
totalité des personnes adultes à risque
de faire des formes graves
c'est la seule solution est la seule
solution sauf qu'on parle beaucoup en ce
moment de ce fameux plafond de verre de
la vaccination en france mais aussi à
l'étranger
il faut que les soignants se fassent
vacciner a redit olivier verront 50 %
seulement de soignants on n'est pas dans
son vacciner ça pourrait devenir
obligatoire si jugé insuffisant en
septembre a dit le ministre de la santé
sabrina délit
vous êtes pour pour cette vaccination
contrainte en septembre notamment dans
les ehpad ans est pour vous la question
évidemment est primordial un bien sûr
bien sûr nous aujourd'hui dire qu'on est
pauvre qu'on est contre on déplore tout
d'abord qu'il faille d'une obligation
vaccinale pour contraindre les soignants
à se faire vacciner notamment les
soignants nepad qui travaille auprès de
personnes âgées particulièrement
vulnérables particulièrement fragile
donc nous surtout voudrait que ces
soignants se mettent un point notre
place à nous famille quand le virus est
arrivé on a enfermé nos parents on les a
complètement clos très ça posait
problème à personne contiennent les
familles à l'écart où nous et
l'isolément par an ça n'a posé de
problème à personne nous tenait tout
autre discours
on fait ça pour protéger les non
résidents à ce moment là c'est encore
leurs résidents s'étaient tues nos
parents hélas aujourd'hui ils ont la
possibilité puisque c'est pas que le
directeur qui décide tout son
établissement en ouvert des portes de
fermer les portes d'un protocole c'est
cher qu'un chaque soignant peut décider
par lui-même
hélas aujourd'hui ont une grosse
réticence moi je trouve ça vraiment
dommage d'autant que aujourd'hui vous
avez quand même des directeurs d'ehpad
qu'ils nous disent
havel si telle et telle famille n'est
pas vaccinée vous ne pouvez pas accéder
en temps chambre où on ne pourra pas
retrouver une vie normale
tant qu'on n'aura pas une bulle
d'immunité de 75% à peu près surtout
l'ehpad donc avec 90 95 % des résidents
matinée on n'y arrivera jamais si on
avec un taux aussi bas
le soignant n'est pas vacillé donc nous
on déplore je voudrais tout simplement
pour tout moment on essaie bulle de
protection aussi bien pour les
résidences pour les soignants les fans
dangereux jeu nous sommes beaucoup à
vous êtes fait vacciner mais c'est pas
suffisant peut pas tout faire il faut
qu'on avance ensemble
philippe besset c'est vrai qu'en italie
on a écarté des soignants qui ne
viennent pas se faire vacciner au texas
par exemple ils sont suspendus on a
beaucoup parlé de déontologie
que c'est une faute morale pour certains
observateurs de dettes soignants et
notamment dans les ehpad et de ne pas
être vaccinés votre opinion là dessus
est ce qu'il faut tout simplement la
rendre obligatoire et ne pas tergiverser
ne pas avoir la main qui tremble à la
rentrée si si le chiffre n'est pas assez
suffisant pour les soignants oui c'est
assez clair on a dit suffisamment mais
c'était une obligation déontologique le
ministre laisse encore deux mois les
mois d'été à tout le monde pour prendre
ses responsabilités et il s'y est hors
de question pour un trognon de mettre la
vie des patients dont il a la charge en
danger donc oui si jamais si jamais à la
fin de l'été bien on ne t'aime pas un
chiffre qui atteint 80 à 90% comme les
résidents des ehpad
il faudra passer par la fin de
l'obligation cycle est alors sa variante
delta en tout cas il inquiète évidemment
le monde entier on le disait tout à
l'heure à l'australie le royaume uni le
portugal ou encore la la russie où ça se
passe pas très bien en ce moment à mon
secours justement le maire sergueï
sobianine a fait un point sur sur cette
ennemie d'emilie côté la situation à
moscou reste très difficile
quant au nombre de nouveaux cas
identifiés de co vide on reste à peu
près au même niveau mais c'est un niveau
très élevé le niveau record de toutes
les périodes principal le nombre
d'hospitalisations a augmenté et celui
des lieux occupés à moscou est proche de
15 mille le nombre de morts dans des
hôpitaux a également augmenté depuis la
semaine dernière
ça c'est pour planter le décor alors
qu'on le rappelle la réussite est le
premier à avoir son bac sans mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya une vraie défiance de la
population vers la vaccination les
autorités de la capitale russe qui ont
adopté plusieurs mesures qui s'apparente
il faut bien le dire une forme de
vaccination obligatoire pour aller au
restaurant pour se faire soigner à
l'hôpital il faut être vaccinés à moscou
clairement bruno meyer ban book est un
grand défenseur de la vaccination ce
qu'il faut faire la même chose en france
écoutez on veut dire pour le moment
encore
nous n'avons pas atteint ce fameux
plafond il est très probable que nous
l'atteignons rapidement aux environs de
65% de primo vacciner comme dans les
autres pays aux états unis en israël
effectivement à ce moment là il faudra
voir si en septembre il y à une
recirculation importante du virus
il faudra très probablement on va dire
contre 1 de la population à choisir la
vaccination et les moyens à disposition
sont d'abord l'instauration du pass
sanitaires dans les activités
quotidiennes et le second très
probablement comme suggéré par
l'académie de médecine c'est le
déremboursement des tests pcr fait pour
convenances personnelles ou pour raison
de voyages ce sont deux mesures certes
difficile mais qui permettront à ceux
qui ne sont pas vaccinés d'être mis face
à leurs responsabilités effectivement il
serait hasardeux voire dangereux que des
personnes prennent des risques d'abord
pour eux mêmes et engendre des coûts
pour la société ensuite mettre en danger
d'autres personnes notamment évidemment
lorsqu'on travaille en ehpad faire
introduire un virus dans un ehpad y
compris lorsque la très grosse majorité
des pensionnaires sont vaccinés vacciner
fait prendre malgré tout un risque de
décès directs de personnes et donc
effectivement il faut absolument se
faire vacciner dans ces circonstances
c'est vrai navet guéri on imagine que
vous avez eus ces conversations s'est
tous retrouvés à table
voilà et l'opinion évidemment de chacun
est libre et c'est un débat compliqué de
deux personnes qui ne souhaitent pas se
faire vacciner
vous vous êtes pour ce genre voilà deux
mesures un petit peu peut-être hypocrite
pour pour certains parce que si on
commence à faire payer au lait les pcr
si on on a interdit aux gens voilà de
deux voyages et d'aller dans les
restaurants et bien les gens seront
obligés d'aller se faire vacciner vous
vous êtes pour justement vous parce
qu'on imagine que vous vos contraintes
elles sont évidemment pas du ressort du
confort vous avez envie de voir vos
proches dans les ehpad et c'est bien
normal
oui tout à fait et pour ceux qui sont
pas décidés non entière que les
prochaines en ehpad
petit groupe d'un petit noyau de départ
on a quand même deux mamans et un papa
qui ciment récemment donc on a eu
beaucoup de décès est vraiment le petit
groupe initial ça ne peut pas continuer
comme ça on sait qu majoritairement
c'est le personnel qui fait rentrer la
vaccination qui fait rentrer le virus
pendant deux mois en ehpad auprès nos
parents attention je ne les condamne pas
j'allais bien pas ils ont une vie oui
donc ils peuvent avoir le virus beaucoup
sont jeunes permettra symptomatique
mais leur travail c'est travailler avec
et aux côtés de personnes fragiles donc
ils se doivent de les protéger
aujourd'hui moi je suis encore jeune je
suis latine et je suis vacciné d'autres
familles on se donne pas tout de suite
ont retrouvé leurs parents
aujourd'hui après l'année l'année et
demi qu'on a vécu de cauchemar tour ça
on est tous sur le même plan mais en
particulier les résidents des factures
étaient enfermés c'était vraiment
d'instruction personne ne peut pas nous
dire au bout d'un an et demi on
entrevoit le bout du tunnel pour
convenance personnelle
moi j'ai pas envie de faire vacciner je
ferai des tests ont arrêté un soignant
n'est pas ne va pas se faire tester
trois fois où toutes les 72 heures ou 30
heures par semaine pardon donc
aujourd'hui oui la vaccination nous
semble la réponse adéquate et je pense
en effet que il est dommage qu'on soit
obligé d'arriver à contraindre les
soignants en particulier et la
population en général et que ça devrait
être un geste citoyen pour s'en sortir
et puis il ya ça ensemble s'en sortir
vraiment pour nous tous philippe besset
c'est un débat délicat parce que des
anti vaccins voilà on en connaît tous et
c'est une opinion qui est répandue et
qui se respecte
à côté de cela on écoute les statuts
pasteur je vous propose d'écouter de
réagir après les personnes non vaccinées
contribuer de façon disproportionnée à
la transmission une personnes non
vaccinées à douze fois plus de risque de
transmettre le sar ce kof 2 qu'une
personne vaccinée en l'absence de
mesures de contrôle un pic de
spécialisation comparable à celui de
l'automne 2020 pourraient être observés
visant principalement les non vaccinés
voilà pour le constat philippe besset
qu'est ce que vous dites à ces gens qui
ont peur du vaccin qui ont peut-être pas
confiance quand on voit cette donne est
tout simplement une personne en fac ci
n'est qu'il ya douze fois plus de risque
de transmettre le virus à mes princesses
ici les philosophes ont répondu à la
question la liberté de chacun s'arrête
où commence celle de l'autre
il est question de collectivités il est
question de l'arrêt de la façon dont
nadon on vit dans une collectivité
ce n'a envie de vivre tout seul dans son
appartement ma foi grand bien face à
ceux qui veulent vivre tout seul mais à
partir du moment où on met par son
comportement la vie des autres en danger
ce n'est plus possible en fait ce n'est
plus et c'est ça qui n'est plus aussi
donc c'est une obligation pour ma part
j'ai toujours considéré comme
déontologie mais ça ne pose absolument
aucun problème qu'elle devienne légal si
si si ça doit être levé 6 à 2 si ça doit
être ça devrait pas être devrait être
même pas être sûr de ce un débat cette
affaire tout le monde quand il dit dans
une collectivité surtout avec des
personnes à risque ne devrait se faire
vacciner sans se poser de questions en
cycle est vraiment très contrariant
d'avoir à débattre il ya quelque chose
d'autre qui enquête en ce moment et là
la collectivité joue à fond c'est l'euro
de foot évidemment cette compétition on
a vu que dd et 300 supporters avaient
été testés positifs hier ils sont
rentrés de finlande la semaine dernière
je vous propose avant de faire réagir
bruno megaman d'écouter le ministre
allemand de l'intérieur sur ce sujet je
trouve cela irresponsable que des
dizaines de milliers de gens se
rassemblent sur des espaces étroits dans
des pays classés à risque à cause du
très contagieux variant delta comme cela
est le cas actuellement en angleterre
dénommé garonne je m'adresse évidemment
médecin que vous n'êtes quand vous voyez
ces stades remplis de demande à nouveau
qu est ce que vous vous dites c'est
totalement irresponsable comme le dit
le ministre allemand oui tout à fait on
va dire il faut effectivement
extrêmement prudents aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de pays ont été
identifiés en rouge comme étant encore
avec une circulation virale importante
une prévalence élevée du variant delta
ça serait dommage évidemment de s'y
rendre de ne pas prendre de précautions
et de ramener le virus avec soin en
france et de faire naître en cluster ça
vaut du cher le fait d'assister à un
match de foot il faut bien sûr être
prudents respectez toutes les
recommandations émises par les autorités
sanitaires
et malheureusement au vu des
circonstances actuelles accepter que
peut-être regarder un match chez soi
devant la télévision et finalement le
mieux pour la collectivité
merci en tout cas tous les 3 bruno mais
garvan sabrina des mairies et philippe
besset d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france